nous avons posé des questions beaucoup
de questions et nous avons eu beaucoup
de d'absence de réponse et face à ce
constat-là nous nous voulons aller sur
les propositions alternatives de
financement puisque nous avons d'autres
choses à proposer que l'impôt sur la vie
qui est en réalité le cœur de la réforme
du gouvernement
[Musique]
parce qu'on est cette volonté d'aller
jusqu'à l'article 7 et là on voit bien
que de toute façon quelque soit les
questions qu'on pose il y a une espèce
de surdité totale de du groupe
Renaissance à toutes nos questions mais
aussi à toutes nos amendements donc on
avance et donc on retire tous les
amendements pour passer à la question
des recettes qui est quand même aussi
centrale dans ce débat sur les retraites
[Musique]
chers collègues de la nuit Pesse sortez
enfin tous vos amendements qu'on arrive
au coeur nucléaire du 7e amendement
qu'on le vote non mais pas 1000 pas 1000
sortez 10000 amendements qu'on puisse
arriver à l'article 7 nous voulons avoir
le débat continué de retirer vos
amendements
de rien vous êtes né avant la honte il y
a un truc qui va pas chez vous qui
retarde le débat
[Applaudissements]
je crois qu'ici ceux qui n'ont pas envie
que le débat avance ce sont les
macronistes nous assistons à un tunnel
d'obstruction assez phénoménal
[Musique]